we're going to be getting even more star
trek on our screens as star trek academy
gets green lit
welcome to scitec your sci-fi tv a movie
channel
[Music]
we already have
five star trek series coming on our
screens in 2021 and it looks like the
kurtzman juggernaut of star trek for
paramount plus is going to add two more
tv shows
we already know about the section 31
with empress giorgio potentially
returning a tv show that i would really
love to see because michelle yo's
character when she left disco
broke my heart a little bit and to be
honest and a big chunk of my interest in
that tv series died the moment she left
but now we're also getting announced
that we may be getting starfleet academy
according to deadline gaia violio
co-creator of the abstentious tv series
has already been signed up to begin very
early pre-production planning for this
tv series so what does that mean well
she'll be coming on as a showrunner in
the very early stages of development to
try to figure out which direction they
want to make this tv show going where do
they want it to go what do they want it
to be about
also how would it fit in with the rest
of the tv series that are currently
being shown because obviously we have
shows in several different time periods
at the moment which time frame do we
want starfleet academy to fit into now
there's not a great deal to say about
the show yet because they don't even
know what it's going to look like but we
can make a few guesses based on what
we've seen with the other tv series and
the other things kurtzman has done with
star trek so far
for one thing i'd say that all of the
series we're getting this year are all
very different
if you think about lower decks as the
adult animation i keep calling it a love
letter to the next generation and that's
how i feel about it so many references
back to the show i really love of the
star trek the next generation
and we have prodigy a children's
animated tv show that some people argue
is actually the best tv show star trek
we have on our screens at the moment we
have picard a character-driven drama
really and then we have discovery a
space opera
now strange new worlds looks like it's
going to be very much an episodic trying
to return back to something like we used
to get to star trek and they want to try
to get the original fans back online
they want to very much have the original
feeling of the original series so that's
going to be different again
like i say if section 31 comes back i
could see that being a gritty suspense
drama a very tense tv show with lots of
political backstabbing and things like
this going on basically a spy drama
we're going to see a warts and all
version of starfleet a more realistic
version of what humanity is really like
in that type of tv show so there we
could have six very different types of
show where would starfleet academy fit
in
my fear is they will try to do basically
a teen drama and it will become star
trek beverly hills 90210
if you think about it they're going to
have very pretty people around 18 19 20
years old there's going to be a lot of
relationship angst and trying to figure
out how to pass the whatever test is
coming up there'll be probably half a
series based around the kobayashi maru
and their emotional tension trying to
get through that there'll be lots of
them trying to figure out where they fit
in in the universe and understanding
different species and so on and so on
i get a lot of comments basically on
this channel about a lot of star trek
and star wars becoming woke if you think
a lot of the shows that we've got
already awoke
the danger for this show is that it
could become
dripping with this woke ideology a term
i absolutely hate
but i can kind of understand what people
mean when they say that rather than the
story driving the show political
ideology does
this is a tv show that if they do decide
to go this way and i genuinely can't
think of another way they could take it
it's not a show i want to see
it's it's not going to teach us anything
about star trek particularly it's not
going to really teach us anything about
the federation
i don't really see
what it adds to the rest of the tv
series unless they decide to go a
completely left field direction and sort
of have
cadets caught on a starship somewhere
almost like voyager mixed with tng and
there was actually a
ds9 episode with cadets on board a
defiant class starship and i forget the
name of it now but unless they go sort
of that direction i really don't see how
this is going to be more than like i say
90210 with star trek attached on the
side somewhere
but guys what do you think about this
announcement what do you think about
there being seven star trek series on
the go they're almost keeping up with
star wars for all the different tv shows
they're going to be producing the next
couple years
do you think they will all fit together
are we getting a little confused with
the timelines being all over the place
as it is please leave a comment tell me
what you think about this news and what
do you think we can expect from this tv
show and if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out
please hit that join button and become a
side tracker and help me produce more
content and you can come and join us on
facebook the link is in the description
as always guys please stay safe
i'll see you next time